[Música]
Todos hemos visto las balas en los
cuerpos de nuestros niños para aquellos
que no lo sepan tienen cientos de
agujeros en sus cuerpos saben quién
fabrica algunos de estos casquillos la
empresa chedrix
una empresa Franco italiana
hoy el equipo de los observadores les
trae una edición especial sobre la
represión de las protestas en Irán el
mes pasado documentamos el uso
generalizado de escopetas de bombeo por
parte de las fuerzas de seguridad
iraníes incluyendo la fuerza militar de
la guardia Revolucionaria los basic los
manifestantes iraníes nos enviaron fotos
de cartuchos que recogieron durante las
manifestaciones al menos 13 cartuchos
tenían el logo del fabricante de armas
Franco italiano chedit la presencia de
estos cartuchos en Irán constituiría una
violación de la reglamentación de la
Unión Europea que prohíbe la exportación
directa o indirecta de equipos que
puedan ser utilizados para la represión
interna en Irán Como por ejemplo las
armas de fuego la munición o accesorios
en las redes sociales muchos iraníes
mostraron su descontento ante estos
hechos que revelamos algunos
manifestantes incluso hicieron grafitis
hablando de lo irónico de la situación
ellos se preguntan por qué las vacunas
contra la gripe y el Coby 19 están bajo
en barco en Irán pero los cartuchos de
escopeta no lo están nosotros los Franco
iraníes exigimos una investigación
contra la empresa chedric exigimos que
todos los responsables de haber enviado
cartuchos a los basic rindan cuentos
ante la justicia esta investigación fue
realizada por
ellihani periodista de los observadores
de France 24 y de rfi desde el inicio de
las protestas el pasado mes de
septiembre tras la muerte de maxa a mini
ha estado en contacto regular con la
población iraní en octubre encontré Esta
foto es un cartucho de escopeta
recuperado tras una manifestación en
Irán si uno se fija bien puede ver algo
escrito en el culote
[Música]
contacté al hombre que tomó la foto me
dijo que había recorrido este cartucho
después de una manifestación en jazz el
28 de septiembre me dio la ubicación
exacta
[Música]
otra persona entera nos envió una foto
de un cartucho similar este tiene el
número 12 escrito cuatro veces en el
culote y cuatro estrellas busque chelite
en internet y encontré esto resultó que
cherite es un fabricante de munición
Franco italiano Esta es su página web
aquí se ven sus cartuchos con la palabra
chelite en el culote y aquí está el logo
con las estrellas y el número 12
fabrican cartuchos vacíos con cute
metálico para escopetas luego los venden
en todo el mundo a otros fabricantes que
los llenan de munición
de cartuchos vacíos del mundo tienen
fábricas en Francia e Italia pero la
Unión Europea impuso un embargo a la
venta de estos productos a Irán Así que
quería saber cómo acabaron esos
cartuchos fabricados en Francia e Italia
siendo utilizados en Irán contra los
manifestantes nuestro periodista publicó
un mensaje en el que le pedía a los
manifestantes iraníes que fotos de la
munición usada y recuperada en las
manifestaciones su mensaje fue
ampliamente difundido y los
manifestantes enviaron fotos tomadas en
varias ciudades de Irán en las que se
veía todo tipo de municiones entre estas
una persona encontró un cartucho chedit
en maabat y un grupo de activistas envió
también fotos de otros 10 cartuchos jedi
en todo el país en total 13 cartuchos de
esta munición fueron recuperados en las
manifestaciones realizadas en ocho
ciudades diferentes una de las personas
que respondió a nuestro llamado fue el
miembro de la milicia basic según él el
equipamiento estándar de sus unidades
son estos cartuchos transparentes como
este que está lleno de bolitas de
plástico sin embargo añadió que durante
las manifestaciones de este año los
basics recibieron cartuchos de escopeta
como estos que contienen balines
metálicos según la ONU los perdigones
metálicos nunca deben ser utilizados en
las manifestaciones Pero estos han sido
utilizados en Irán en las fotos que nos
enviaron los manifestantes se ven las
heridas causadas por los balines
metálicos los impactos de los perdigones
de plomo también cuando estos perdigones
impactan el rostro pueden provocar
ceguera como ha sido el caso de decenas
de manifestantes iraníes amnistía
internacional afirma que al menos 20
personas han muerto por disparos de
escopeta de bombeo durante las protestas
en ira según nuestra investigación los
cartuchos de la marca están presentes de
hace ya varios años son utilizados sobre
todo por los cazadores
lo que hice fue Buscar en foros de casa
los cazadores iraníes reciben una cuota
anual de 100 cartuchos de la marca shein
y resulta que muchos de estos cartuchos
utilizan componentes de chedite miren
este mensaje de 2014
Hey amigos en el culote metálico de los
cartuchos chajín de la cuota de este año
dice chedite y en la caja dice Majin
hitaly
en este foro encontramos cientos de
mensajes que hacen referencia a los
cartuchos chedit estos mensajes se
remontan al menos al año 2011 muchos
mencionan también a Chaín que es una
gama de cartuchos de casa que son
producidos por la empresa chaid shiroudi
Military industries que es una empresa
que forma parte del grupo Estatal iraní
amig que es justamente objeto de
sanciones por parte de la ONU Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea hablamos con
cinco expertos diferentes sobre las
sanciones impuestas por la Unión Europea
a Irán según ellos las sanciones no sólo
se aplican a los cartuchos de escopeta
sino también a sus componentes tanto si
están destinados a ser utilizados por
cazadores como por los servicios de
seguridad
las sanciones de la Unión Europea se
aplican en las escopetas de bombeo y de
casa su munición y componentes asociados
no hay excepciones para la casa u otros
usos
los expertos consultados afirman también
que sherid es responsable de controlar
sus cadenas de venta hasta el final
independientemente de los intermediarios
En consecuencia la empresa debe
asegurarse de que sus productos no sean
vendidos en la República islámica una
cosa es decir que una empresa no sabe lo
que ocurre con sus productos
pero ahora sí lo saben
ahora saben qué parte de su munición
está siendo utilizada para la represión
en Irán
la empresa debería investigar qué fue lo
que sucedió
intentamos comunicarnos varias veces con
la empresa hdid Pero no recibimos
respuesta a nuestras preguntas en
Francia las mujeres iraníes presentaron
sus denuncias ante el parlamento francés
tuvimos la oportunidad de ser recibidas
en el parlamento los diputados estaban
sorprendidos prometieron transmitir la
información al Ministerio de asuntos
exteriores el Ministerio de asuntos
exteriores francés nos informó que se
estaba llevando a cabo una investigación
y que si las conclusiones demostraban
una violación de La regulación europea
en materia de exportación adoptarían
sanciones contra los autores también
hablamos con uno de los parlamentarios
que se reunió con las manifestantes
iraníes hay una investigación en curso y
estamos tratando de obtener toda la
información posible no hay indicios de
que infligiera el embargo No sabría
decir si este material fue vendido a un
país que después se lo revendió
para los iraníes con quien hablamos la
normativa de la Unión Europea es Clara
[Música]
Permítame decirles que así la venta sea
directa o indirecta es una violación del
embargo la lucha acaba de empezar créame
que tenemos mucha energía mujer vida
libertad
[Aplausos]